So I am going to switch to, sometimes people say the stepsister, the stepsister that lets
the sister have all the benefit and do all the work and stuff.
But there's been a lot of work from the stepsister.
So let's talk a little bit about it.
So, you know, I think we're all very familiar with CD38 as a target.
In fact, CD38 is the highest, you know, receptor on the surface of the plasma cell.
Hundreds of thousands of receptors.
So it's a great target on the, you know, on the surface of the cell.
But it's also, you know, widely dispersed along the microenvironment.
And so it's on Tregs, Bregs, other immunosuppressive, you know, cells, as we know.
And so it works by two things.
One, it works by directly targeting the cancer cell, but it also decreases the immunosuppressive
microenvironment of the bone marrow.
Now, this, you know, back in the day, I don't know how many of you guys follow this, but
back in the day, it was.
It was a true race.
It was Dara versus Issa, and it was a true race, and everybody presenting data.
And then all of a sudden, Issa got a flat tire, maybe two flat tires.
I actually think somebody knifed the tires, okay?
And there we go.
So when we think about newly diagnosed myeloma, I'll just step back and say, our first decision,
as Sergio told us earlier, is that are they a transplant candidate?
Are they not?
And if they're not a transplant candidate, are they frail and are they not?
And so.
I'm going to show some data about that.
Now, I do like to say that myeloma is an art.
We paint various pictures.
Everybody might like one of these different pictures better.
I like them all.
I'd love to be in a museum.
But that said, we can take all the drugs that we have and all these, you know, scenarios
and put them together and we paint our own picture.
What's the best induction for transplant eligible, transplant ineligible, the frail?
Do we do treatment till forever?
Is it?
Do we use one, two, three, four drugs?
What do we do, right?
Should MRD be used?
These are questions that we still are answering, but it's becoming more and more a question
of, yes, we start with a quad, right?
The first thing I want to show, one of my favorite ongoing studies, and that is basically
the GMMG HD7 study.
This was one of the original studies to have MRD as an endpoint, and it was VRD versus
E-sub-VR.
VRD as induction therapy, and the bottom left shows that actually by MRD negativity, the
quad worked over the triplet.
Harmut initially presented this in 2021 at ASH.
Here we are in 2026.
This regimen is not approved by the FDA.
If MRD was accepted as an endpoint, this would have been approved five years ago.
So that's how long it takes for some of these to develop.
But one thing I want to point out about this study is that we're going to have the four
curves.
I'm hoping to have the four curves at the end of this year.
The four curves is no CD38 as induction or maintenance, CD38 only as induction, CD38
only as maintenance, or both.
I actually think both is going to win, and I think ESA is going to lead the way on how
to move this forward.
Okay.
So other things that ESA has done, ESA has been compared or has been combined a lot with
KRD, right?
ESA KRD is not a regimen, I think, a lot of it.
A lot of us are using.
But in fact, if you look at some of the studies, like the E-SKIA trial, you see a very high
MRD negativity rate.
And now with follow-up from ASCO and EHA, sustained MRD negativity rate, really high
rates of sustained, more than half of the patients.
It also was used in the SKYLARC trial.
The SKYLARC trial is probably Sergio's least favorite trial.
And this is a Boston trial, and this is a way to maybe say that you don't have to do
transplant.
But if you see in the bottom right, those people...
Those people that have high-risk cytogenetic abnormalities, probably not going to transplant
is not a good idea.
Right, Sergio?
All right.
So you're still my mentor.
So the MITUS study, I'm not going to say much more of the MITUS study.
The only thing I want to say about the MITUS, in the standard risk arms, the ones that got
MRD negativity, the maintenance is lenalidomide.
In the high-risk, the ones that are MRD positive, the maintenance is actually ESA IBER, which
is kind of cool.
We'll see that.
My favorite high-risk...
High-risk study is the GMG concept trial.
So Katja and Lisa put this forward.
This is what I do, although often I do DARA because patients want a subcutaneous versus
an IV.
So it's four drug for the transplant-eligible induction, a transplant, four drug consolidation
for four cycles, and then ESA KR forever.
For me, it's two to three years until they actually have two to three years of MRD negativity.
And they have...
It's shown one of the best progression-free survival rates for high-risk.
This is high-risk multiple myeloma, both transplant-eligible on the left and transplant
non-eligible on the right, showing PFS at five years of more than 50%.
That's a win.
That's a big win in my mind for high-risk multiple myeloma.
All right.
What about the transplant-ineligible?
There is a benefit, quote unquote, to the use of bortezomib.
We were all hoping there wouldn't be a benefit.
Right.
So this is ESA RD versus ESA bortezomib RD.
And on the left, you see higher rates of MRD negativity.
On the right, the progression-free survival, there just hasn't been enough follow-up.
It probably will diverge over time.
But the benefit, in my mind, of using this is weekly bortezomib for 12 cycles, and then
every other week for six more cycles, you can do it, and it's actually very effective.
There's also the EMRO study that looked at a quad in the...
The transplant-ineligible.
And the subset of this is the frail patient population.
Now, this is modified IMW frail score, looking based on age, modified Charleston comorbidity
index in ECOG.
And you can see on the left, frail, on the right, non-frail, that the quad is better
than the triplet.
In my mind, quad really should be used for the majority of patients.
And I'll just say quality of life looks really good no matter...
Which arm you're on.
To Amrita's question, the on-body device.
So this is an on-body device.
Professor LeLue has actually presented this at multiple congresses.
You put it on, you hit the button in the middle, and it administers the esotuximab over five
minutes.
Patients, some of the patients didn't want that.
And so the nurse was allowed to give it like Dertumab to just give a, you know, basically
a five, three to five minute injection.
But that said, equivalency rates between sub-Q and IV.
Surprise, surprise, okay?
Now, in Europe, this actually has received a positive response from CHOMP.
And so hopefully in the next, even the next couple months, this could be approved in Europe.
In the US, they're looking at the package right now with the hope that we'll get access
to this this year in 2026.
So that's in relapse refractory.
But there is a GMG.
One of my other favorite GMG studies is HD8, which is sub-Q versus IV and transplant eligible
patients.
And on the right, GMG HD9, looking at esotuximab and ibertamide versus ibertamide as maintenance
therapy.
Pretty cool studies, actually.
Okay.
And with that, I'll conclude that ESA, yes, it is the stepchild.
It might actually be graduating to a better stepchild by the end of this year with sub-Q
administration.
Thank you for your attention.